c'est une double préparation que doit
accomplir le domaine de dampierre en
yvelines avant sa réouverture le château
entamé sa rénovation juste avant le
confinement
les travaux ont repris au lendemain du
lundi de pâques avec le montage de cette
impressionnante échafaudage 50 compagne
ans at elle a bien sécuriser le chantier
avant l'accueil du public dans les
jardins c'était chevaux d'âge ne restera
pas comme ça derrière et fak
l'échafaudage est achevée il reste plus
que la façade orientale a terminé et
bien on aura un parapluie qui va
protéger le temps de refaire la
couverture et ensuite il ya une bâche et
j'invite tout le monde à découvrir là
bas je pense que ça va être un petit
clin d'oeil à l'histoire de dampierre et
donc cette bâche veuve a ceinturé et
ensuite eh bien il faut travailler sur
les charpentes et couvertures les
enduits les fenêtres on estime à environ
36 mois le temps à consacrer pour la
restauration du logis terres du château
ça y est dl de part et d'autre de la
cour aux chantiers s'ajoute le nouveau
protocole sanitaire qu'il a fallu mettre
en place marquage au sol pour respecter
les distances en cas de files d'attentes
sens de circulation pour empêcher les
croisements installations de plexiglas
ok c'est au nouveau salon de thé dont la
terre à ce qui avait été installé va
disparaître même les activités proposées
sont repensés on nous a interdit les
gaules fait on s'attarde les rosalies et
les barques mais par contre la golf les
l'attelage tirée par les mules
américaine est maintenu et donc du coup
on met que la moitié des personnes en
fait on applique le protocole des
transports en plus des transports
publics dans un transport privé une
ouverture de saison retardé mais avec
une grande nouveauté des plans d'un
jardin pittoresque ont été retrouvés
dans le château les vestiges du jardin
du bosquet des chimères ont été
restaurés une balade de 1.5 km est
proposé au public avec des panneaux
explicatifs de son histoire pour les
plus aventuriers un jeu d'énigmes à
résoudre pour retrouver le jardinier
disparu la veille de la visite du roi en
juin 1748 avec plusieurs étapes dont la
première le labyrinthe restituer en
clôture de châtaigniers et 6 à
labyrinthes plus loin c'est une grotte
il ya des endroits où il y avait des
cascades et on explique voilà que les
cascades ont disparu mais on est à
l'endroit où il y avait des cascades
donc à chaque fois on a essayé de faire
des points d'attraction pour faire
découvrir l'histoire de ce jardin
complètement oublié complètement effacés
d'ailleurs sur le terrain à l'exception
des vestiges comme ça ouverture le 30
mai pour profiter du parc du château de
dampierre
les visiteurs sont attendus avec
impatience et l'équipe réfléchit déjà
aux nouvelles activités pour la saison
2010 21 comme un échafaudage consacrée à
l'accueil du public pour suivre les
travaux de ce chantier si particulier